[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
hello once again to the endgame class my
name is Caleb Dendy and today I'm going
to be walking you through some really
instructive attend games from the
nation's Cup that is currently going on
hosted by chess comm one player that
definitely I have been following is the
wonderful Fabiano Cara wanna who is
miraculously playing board two for the
US team with Hikaru Nakamura holding
down that board one and in the first two
rounds Cara wanna actually played two
really instructive games where he ends
up in just a slightly slightly better
endgame
that many players would think don't have
many winning chances at all and then he
managed to push them to their absolute
limit and win one both of those games
before the US team so I wanted to start
with a couple of his games so jumping
into it here this is his game between
against Santosh Vineet on the India team
this is the opening now I don't know if
you read the title of the class it's not
an openings class so I don't know what
we're doing here okay thank goodness
some pieces are being traded okay all
right
more pieces getting traded okay there go
the rooks okay waiting for some slightly
more piece trades Queen takes d5 Knight
takes d5 and wait a second I feel like
we can do better and get one more trade
off the board here 97 takes takes and
now h5 by white and we have arrived at
the end game in question here so of
course the story of this endgame is
going to be that of the two bishops
for Fabiana Cara wanna against the
bishop and the night for NVIDIA and
while this is an advantage it is not the
easiest one to convert definitely here
Black has a very solid position without
many weaknesses at all so let's see how
Fabi managed dismantled vidiots position
and how he did manage to take out his
opponent this game for the US team black
plays the
Smoove 97 to start with now of course in
97 opens up this bishop for black also
hints at rerouting this night to some
other squares 97 itself is actually a
threatening move believe it or not black
is making a threat with this move not
necessarily to play Knight c5 hitting
this Bishop but to play Knight f6 when
all of a sudden that might be a rude
awakening for white to realize that this
pawn is slightly indefensible
so Fabiano of course notices this threat
plays the move Bishop d1 just a guard h5
now after Knight f6 we get the move king
d3 on the board force guarding this pawn
now Bishop e6 for black but Fabi is
happy to push this pawn up to f4 and now
comes a great defensive move from vidi
that I wanted to highlight here if
you're not careful what is white going
to do well white actually has a really
simple plan to create some targets on
the Kings side these bishops look
perhaps a little bit passively placed on
this back rank here but they are
actually very very threatening pieces
from such a long distance as well and in
fact if you give white just a couple
moves g4 and g5 are going to come on the
board and this is going to be suddenly a
very very difficult position for vidi to
hold so for example if Knight d5 takes
takes at five well suddenly this pawn is
already falling off the board of course
I didn't play this position very well
for black in those three moves but it
just goes to show you how dangerous
these positions actually can really can
be if you're not totally on your guard
keeping track of all the threats so now
that you know White's plan I challenge
you guys at home to find a move for the
deep to keep the game going a bit see
what he did here to take away these
threats of g4 and g5 creating more
targets what could be done what could be
done
it's that the same shirt you sign I am
wearing the same shirt as the road to
2000 class that happened about 10
minutes ago you guys caught me you guys
caught me send all complaints to our
wardrobe department okay I'm not gonna
wait for the delay too much longer here
of course the move by the deep is the
move g6 this is the nice defensive move
by the deep to clarify some things on
the Kings side and alleviate a lot of
this extra kingside space that Fabiano
has gained by pushing this pawn up to
age 5
now this pawn can't really stay on this
h5 square if you do play the move g6
perhaps you're asking for a little bit
too much trouble here against g4 I think
yet the move G takes h5 is playable by
black and then the move King e6 and all
of a sudden you know you don't really
have time to get these threats in with
f5 cleanly winning upon instead you have
to play it as a sacrifice to take on
aged 6 and then after move like Knight
g4 all of a sudden your glorious bishop
pair is going to die
so for vidi the tactics do immediately
work out with this h5 pawn and being
just a little bit over extended and so
that is a huge points in the game for
the D with this g6 move he alleviates so
much pressure off of this white position
so if you ever find yourself in an end
game like this where one there's a
bishop bearing down on an age six pawn
like this I myself have had many end
games that look similar to this in the
carrick on the move g6 is a really nice
freeing move if you can achieve it in
this case it was playable cuz F for
blocks this Bishop in other cases it's
usually playable with a king ending up
on this h7 square in my experience this
happens quite often in like Cara Khan
type of end games so g6 a great
defensive move for the deep wanted to
highlight that one age 66 F takes G six
now King e2 by Fabiano is rerouting this
King over to this Kings side
95 comes on the board for vidi now King
f3 and h5 is vidiots attempt to lock
down the position and this is a great
way of playing if you are facing the two
bishops what you want to do is really
clamp down on one specific color complex
of course the weakness of the two
bishops there aren't many but the
weakness is they cannot really pile up
on one square together so as the
defensive sight it's often your task to
create a sort of fortress on these one
color of squares in this case it's going
to be the light squares for black that
he's trying to hold down now ideally
black would actually want to hold down
his fortress on the dark squares because
that is where back has a distinct
advantage black can use two minor pieces
to control dark squares whereas of
course white can only use one but due to
the way that Fabi has placed these pawns
that is actually not going to be
feasible here for vidi so that's why we
see g6 and h5 Bishop d2 now is fabi's
slow improving move and this is what
what these high level players do they
they really take their time in these end
games there's no need to rush anything
the advantage that white has in these
two bishops is going to be a permanent
one sorry excuse me I'm going to be a
permanent one so there's no need to rush
things with with you know crazy moves
like a four just yet Fabi takes this
time improves this pieces and only then
starts to advance these pawns King f6
buying the deep a simple improving move
now c4 is Fabiano's choice after
bringing the bishop to d2 guarding this
be for a square 97 comes on the board by
viddy and now Bishop c3 check is very
nice for Fabi to guard this diagonal of
course if you come to f5 you're asking
for Bishop c2 check so simply King e6
now and Fabi not settling for space just
on the Kings side starts to take some
space on the
we inside as well so the move before it
comes on the board and note how Fabi is
really using these pawns to control
these dark squares rather than the light
squares and once again the reason for
that is these pieces for black are going
to give him a distinct advantage on the
dark squares so Fabia is trying to
compensate for that by putting his pawns
on dark squares to challenge the the
pieces claim to dominance over this
color complex and for that reason I
really do think the best move here for
black would have been to play c5 I think
black really needed to challenge these
dark squares himself not allow Fabi
total reign over the position and play
this move c5 now there's a few options
here that Fabi could go for B take c5 is
actually an interesting choice to create
a slight imbalance in the pawn structure
the move a three would kind of hold the
balance for the moments the move b5 is
even considerable but the point is black
is really gaining a nice strong hold on
these dark squares and I think that's
what was required here of the D instead
though Knight f5 comes on the board and
of course Fabi does not waste any time
here
c5 comes on the board and Fabi is
claiming these dark squares for himself
the bishop c7 and now Bishop e3 check
and you see how easily Bobbie is taking
over both colors of the board here now
after King seven this King is totally
cut off for the moment
once again you can actually start to do
some slightly more fun things here with
white if you're a bit impatient things
like g4 are going to be threats here g4
trying to get this King into the game
now that you've created this sort of
great wall on these two diagonals but
Bobbie 2800 level player has you know
supreme patience and plays Bishop c4 and
this is one of those moves and just kind
of passes the turn back to avid eat
allowing him to to play whatever he
wants here so if your vide try and find
another nice defensive move I'll give
you a hint it looks a lot like the last
defensive move that we
from the deep to give himself some
slight compensation in this endgame
sorry everyone for the coughing I
promise I'm not sick just talking a lot
and swallowing wrong
yeah Bishop d2 was GM move it was a
really nice move by Fabi so of course
the move I'm talking about here is the
move b6 this move does challenge
Bobby's kind of indisputable claim to
the dark squares for just a moment here
allowing vidi to you know kind of fight
back on these dark squares because
that's really what it's all about here
creating this blockade on the dark
squares is the ideal defensive setup
before black now Fabi responds to this
with the move a for taking as much space
as possible over here B takes c5 plate B
takes e5 and now Fabi has this pawn
sitting on c5 which could potentially be
weak but in fact it's quite difficult to
get at this pawn this Knights not really
in good position to challenge it and
neither is this Bishop you know we see
this pawn on a7 kind of in the way the
King kind of in the way of the bishop
coming here and this is the advantage in
extra space that Fabiano has here even
in an endgame with so few pieces on the
board extra space is an advantage and
Fabiano is definitely using it here to
restrict his opponent's pieces to
restrict their activity note also this
d6 square now taken away from the knight
b6 and d6 taken away from the bishop of
course as well and these pieces kind of
find themselves without anything to do
for that reason vidi 8 actually comes up
with a nice improving plan for the
bishop aimed at attacking this pawn that
plan begins with the the strange-looking
move King e8 he simply vacates this
square
allowing his bishop to come over now
Fabiano was not happy with the amount of
space he had so he took even more a5
comes on the board now bishop d8 was met
with Bishop d3 by Fabi eyeing this
square in just a little bit and after
Bishop e7 we do see Bishop b4 come on
the board now that this bishop has left
the d4 square and this is why Fabi put
this Bishop on d3 he's just keeping an
eye on this night making sure it can't
get too active Bishop f6 now was vide
try and Fabi of course continues with
this move ace
and this is a really great way to
generate winning chances in these end
games where material is equal you don't
have a passed pawn but you do just have
slightly better pieces by putting the
pawn so far up the board now all of a
sudden black is going to have to concern
himself with threats of moves like
Bishop b6
this ponen a6 is so close to queening
that if the a pawn ever moves out of the
way look out this a six pawn will become
a queen so this is a great way to press
in these kinds of end games just take as
much space as you can the caveat to that
of course is that you know taking all
this space can create some weaknesses so
just be aware that if you press too hard
create too many weaknesses and give your
opponent targets that's when these end
games start to backfire so the trick is
doing it while making sure your opponent
can't actually use these targets
effectively so Bishop e7 comes on the
board
g4 now does come on the board for
Fabiano Cara Juana this is the the final
step in breaking through here first he
takes all of the Queen side space and
only then is he ready to open up this
Kings side H takes g4 King takes G 493
check ok this King now does have to step
back to f3 and rather then come back to
f5 and allow this White King to do some
more dancing perhaps coming up to e4
perhaps you know we would just see some
more waiting from Fabiano we need
actually comes back to d5 and I think
this is a little bit of a mistake here a
little bit of a mistake I think Knight
f5 was in fact the more resilient
defense just keeping hold of this g6
pawn after the move 95 of course this
does give up the g6 pawn and Fabi
gladly captures it King f8 now this
Bishop is attacked so Bishop a3 now
Knight c7 by viddy challenges this pawn
Bishop d3 is required to guard this pawn
96 is going after the C pawn in return
this was likely vidiots
idea from the beginning giving up this F
pawn
in exchange for the C pawn so Knight
takes e5 is the tactical line and that
vide was hoping for
Bishop c1 now 97 King up to e4 makes
sense Bishop c5 from black and now the
move King f5 on the board for Fabiana
Cara Juana and this is really the the
correct way to play here in all of these
end games you want your King in front of
your past pawn to help support to help
guide it up the board and also to help
control some squares that oppose this
enemy King it's less about having your
king and you'll be super active it's
more about preventing your opponent's
king from blockading your pawn so King e
7 here is trying to take these squares
away from white before it's too late and
after Bishop b2 we see the move Bishop
e3 by black keeping this King firmly
connected to this pawn and now Fabi does
a little bit of maneuvering here Bishop
e2 Knight b6 Bishop f3 attacks upon so
we do see c5 now Bishop f6 is check
Bishop h5 is check and now Bishop back
to e5 and you know this is all well and
good not a ton of progress has actually
been made here by Fabiano he does just
kick this King back to f8 and play some
some attacking moves now c4 comes on the
board and Bobby decides it is finally
time to start trying to push this pawn
so King e4 is nice to keep an eye on the
C pawn and to also start pushing this F
pawn as we do see here now vide plays
the nice move in 97 and after Bishop c3
I'm hoping you guys can find the
defensive setup for the dete here this
is the setup that hopefully should of or
should have allowed him to draw the game
without too much controversy
honestly this setup should have been
good enough for a total total draw see
what you guys can come up with here
hello hello - Akash
okay I get bored waiting for this delay
so the move Bishop e7 is the one I was
looking for once again it's going to be
about this dark square defense if black
can control this f6 square forever then
white is not going to be able to win now
Bishop e7 also comes with an added bonus
that bonus being this is difficult to
stop and so black is getting rid of
White's final pawn on the Queen side so
the move Bishop e2 does come on the
board the 95 check King e5 Knight takes
a 6 bishop takes c4 is a nice trade
Knight c5 by Fabiano kara wanna now
after Bishop - sorry d2 we do see this
Knight come back to g7 check we do see a
repetition at first King up to d5 and
once again it's the dark square blockade
that counts here so King g7 on the board
this Bishop drops back to e2 and now
King f6 like I said for black it's all
about guarding this a5 pond Bishop c4
defends our defense at 5 and I'm sorry
I'm guarding the f6 square against this
f5 pawn so Bishop g4 Knight back to d7
look to see black put all of his pieces
on this f6 Square we should see through
check King g5 Bishop age 3 and now
Bishop f6 is the nice move for black if
one pair of bishops gets traded and it's
a dead dead dead dead dead
draw the knight will sacrifice for the
pawn and the game will end so Bishop d2
is a check instead now King h4 bishop f1
and I think this is the point where the
D finally loses his accurate touch here
so see if you guys at home can find the
way for black to pretty much permanently
blockade the f6 pawn and just alleviate
any winning threats from from white you
really just need one or two more
accurate
moves in this game is going to be dead
now I do want to mention here there is a
a pretty important idea to this end game
for black and that idea is that
let's just play some nonsense moves here
the idea is that this end game is a draw
two bishops cannot be one bishop now the
idea for white is that let's say some
nonsense moves happen this endgame is a
win so the trick for black is to make
sure at all costs that your knight is
the piece that can sacrifice for the F
pawn not the bishop and so with that in
mind the move here as I pointed out is
going to be the move Bishop a1 bishop a1
removes this Bishop from any threat to
force it off of the diagonal and opens
the f6 square for the knight it allows
the King easy access back into the game
the move plate instead is the move
Bishop g5 and this move is more or less
the beginning of the end
Bishop g5 it looks more or less the same
but note that this bishop has far fewer
squares to kind of mess around with then
compared to this long open diagonal only
g5 in h4 also note that the King can no
longer return to the g5 square
immediately Bishop b4 is Fabiano's move
of course avoiding this trade
now after Knight f6 check all of a
sudden the King comes in to e6 and it's
looking more and more difficult to
defend the f6 square Knight e4 is a pass
by the deep but after Bishop to d3 this
is when things have really truly gone
wrong for the deep if you do come back
to f6 the problem is Fabiano is starting
to create some threats here starting to
really create some threats
for example if Bishop e7
sorry I guess there is still night age 5
to worry about but with the move Bishop
e2 Fabiano is already threatening to get
this King further and further away from
from the f6 square and once the King is
kind of vacated then moves like Bishop
e7 started to become very much
considerable with the King away the two
bishops and the King can hopefully force
off these minor pieces from f6 and
advance this pot so Knight g3 was played
instead Knight f6 was actually the
required move to keep the game more or
less going after Knight g3 Fabiano does
get exactly what he wants with the move
f6 perhaps the D was in fact worried
about this move from Bishop e2 with the
idea of cutting off this King like other
concerns in this position I'm not
totally sure
for example Bishop e7 I think is really
going to be a tricky move for example if
Knight back to g4 well now all of a
sudden let's see yeah I don't know I
guess Bishop e7 isn't much of a concern
it is this move Bishop e2 that does give
black some trouble here so I think
though Knight f6 had to be played it was
really the only trike Knight g3 allows
f6 and after takes and takes and King g4
this is where Bobby starts to show his
stuff here this is by no means an easy
endgame to win but it is in fact winning
it's not every day you see two bishops
against a knight so the nice idea for
Fabi first he plays King me five and now
after King f3
he plays a really really great move for
end games like these if God forbid you
ever find yourself in an endgame like
this note that it's not always in your
best interest to take this last pawn the
King and then I are never really going
to threaten to promote this a pawn
sitting here on a7 and so it can be a
very useful tool for you to keep this
pawn on the board for a while while you
figure out what you're doing try and
make some progress against the king and
once you're confident you kind of have
the winning plan or black does manage to
force you to take it only then do you
take the
why is this advantageous well because
the 50 move rule exists and you would
hate to get to move 50 and not have won
the game so by giving yourself a few
extra Tempe to mess around with you keep
this pawn on the board and this is a
great practical way of playing so the
move Bishop a six of course comes on the
board for Fabi keeping this pawn right
where it's at not letting it move not
letting it force itself to be captured
now the trick to this endgame is going
to be the trick to most end games where
it is alone King in the night trying to
defend or a lone keegan a piece trying
to defend against other pieces the trick
is to get these pieces separated so that
is exactly what Fabia tries to do here
you try to create separation between the
king in the night and then you can kind
of work against them independently you
can try to checkmate this king and trap
this Knight and with both threats the
further away the pieces get the more
difficult it is to stop either so the
move 94 of course would be the easiest
way to lose with the pin so 92 comes on
the board now Bishop d2 is already
starting to corral this King taking away
the squares close to the night making it
difficult for the King to stay around
now Knight g3 and the move Bishop g5 by
Fabi this one I don't think is any you
know huge idea just passing the time for
the moment now 94 does come on the board
here it is slightly different after
Bishop d7 we see the move king g4 and
this was the point for vidi he can unpin
Bishop e3 by Fabi and now Knight back to
g3 this Bishop steps up to F 2 and now
vidi finally starts trying to push this
pawn forward forcing it off the board we
see Bishop c6 a4 and Bishop takes so now
the clock is officially on
for Bobby 50 moves to mate 50 moves to
mate from Bishop takes a for King f3
comes on the board
Bishop d4 came back to g4 now once again
the trick here is trying to separate the
King in the night at the same time
threatening simply to
checkmate the King so what you do is you
create awkward situations for the king
where you have to pick one or the other
you either stand by the knight or you
get pushed into a corner so Fabi does
that with this move Bishop d1 check
hitting the King now if you step back to
the side you are unfortunately trapped
on the kind of first rank here in this
case the first file the H file but you
do get to stay with the knight similar
story if you play a king h4 you get to
stay with the knight but you are trapped
on this kind of H file now if you play
King g5 well this is a little bit
different now your king is staying off
of the back rank but you are starting to
separate from the knight and that's why
Fabi plays King III now presenting him
with the exact same difficult decision
do you want to stay by your knight or do
you want to escape with your king Brady
chose escaping with the king but that's
not where the trouble ends Bishop C to
check now and all of a sudden it's the
same decision again do you want to go to
the first or do you want to be free
Vineet chooses freedom king f7 and now
Fabi plays a really really great move
here the king and the knight have been
separated so what does he do he starts
to go about the process of trapping this
Knight Bishop d1 guards h5 prevents this
Knight from coming back into the game
King g6 tries to get this Knight back
but now the move King e6 from Bobby is
nice
guarding more squares around this King
once again the dual threats trapping the
knight or check made in the King now
after Knight age 5 the King has taken
away the f7 square Bishop c2 check comes
on the board all of a sudden you know
we're running out of squares for this
King King g7 and now Bobby I think does
play slightly inaccurately with Qing Yi
7 but it doesn't really matter the he3
was Bishop d3 Knight age 5 and Bishop g5
now and a g3 and came back to e6 and
then okay after Knight h5 find the way
to put away the opponent here
there is more or less just a very very
clean win for Fabi in this position see
if you guys at home can find it
see if you can find it yeah Bishop
Bishop versus Knight has a lot of you
know encourage twins is the term that
the chat used where it takes more than
50 moves to to win the game this is not
the case here though
not the case here so yeah Fabi with
incredible technique in this game so
okay the move of course is king f5 and
now all of a sudden the end is is here
tonight cannot step to f6 then I cannot
step to f4 if the King if the knight
steps to g3 well now this move is quite
simply a trapping the night but the only
score can go to being h1 when of course
Bishop h4 is more than enough
so Nigeria not gonna be played king f7
only move but now after this check King
has to step back here if you step away
well now this Knight is in fact going to
be totally dead I think I think this way
is the simplest Knight and g3 forced now
Bishop d3 and once again this night gets
corralled to the h1 square so King back
to g7 instead and now the nice move
Bishop age four highlights that there
are no squares for this night King age
six
Bishop f7 this Knight is attacked in 97
is a check and now King g4 and the end
is near
no moves for this night King h7 King g5
King h8 King g6 night II 6 and then
Bishop takes east 6 wins the night and
draws the game so don't fall for the
stalemate trap Bishop f6 check played in
the game and Bishop takes g7 is a
checkmate really great stuff from
Fabiana Cara wanna hear wanted to share
this guy this one with you because it
was a killer killer game so what are the
takeaways from this game 1 Fabiana Cara
Wan is a really good chess player to
this idea of taking space on all sides
of the board is really great by Fabiano
he pushes these pawns as
far as they can go creating threats on
both sides of the board and then
creating a passed pawn on the Kings side
using these threats from there it was
just really really great technique by
the world number 2 to get rid of this
defensive Knight our defensive Bishop by
forcing it to trade off once again
Bishop g5 boom just feels a little bit
strange a little bit strange
Bishop a1 would have been so clean and
so easy just keeping this Bishop a mile
away from any kind of tactics okay let
us move on to the next game
thank you for watching techno way all
right moving on we have Kara wanna
against our Tamia artemyev of course a
strong Russian player and this match
from USA against Russia in this Nations
Cup so once again this is not an opening
of class so we're going to skip all of
these moves these moves are irrelevant
to us we are interested in the endgame
so we do see you know there's a d5 pawn
or something on board this is not and oh
wait a second wait a second rook here
Queenie v Queen takes pawn takes okay we
seem to have ourselves in an endgame now
the good news for Fabi is by you know
some kind of luck at this game he is
winning upon by force to start with with
this nice move rook c5 it pays to have
the active rook winning one of these
pawns
now black of course does a very good job
of getting active himself playing to
move a four rook takes e5 a takes p3 a
takes b3 and now after rook a one check
King g2 and rook b1 this rook is
relegated to passivity on the
third-ranked guarding this beep on kind
of forever so my question for you
wonderful people is how do you go about
winning this game with the white pieces
here if your name is Fabiana Cara Juana
how do you create problems for your
opponent
in this position it's really difficult
actually as your rook is tied down to
this beep on
but there is one plan that is a really
great winning plan here that Fabi went
for and executed really really well in
fact so let you guys um try and find
this one it's a great winning plan you
pull up my chat again oh thank you to
Jean for watching it is 2:30 in France
thank you thank you
winning plan my friends winning plan
keyword plan plans last longer than one
move so let me give you the next move
here bye bye black it was Rick be to
check King age three and now age five
now aged 5 I may have spoiled it but
with some arrows I apologize if your
name is Fabiana Carolina then you would
know it easily fair enough so sight out
Karsh actually has the wrong idea for
once the guy is finally wrong so the key
here for white is not to get caught up
with things on the Kings side of the
board because if you just start trying
to win on the Kings side for example
King h4 you're already giving up some of
these pawns over here King g5 king f7
and it's it's gonna be really tough to
win now you've already given up one pawn
on the Kings side and it will be
difficult to to win with more of these
pawns dropping off the board I don't
know if King f7 was actually the most
accurate yes I think King f7 you might
end up winning upon over here but Rick
h3 is a really great move for black
black gets so active taking all these
Kings side pawns it's gonna be tough to
win gonna be tough to win so instead of
that after h5 of course the idea is not
to kind of go crazy on the Kings side
starting to sacrifice these pawns the
idea is to first play g4 giving yourself
the g3 square H takes g4 F takes G for
g5 King g3 and now after rook b1 we
simply secure our second weakness on h3
by or on h2 by playing the move h3 our
rook now does a great job of defending
our two weak weak spots and our King is
actually free to run to the other side
of the board to win this game and that's
what Bobby does here king f7 and now he
makes it look easy
King f3 Ric f1 is a Czech note if you
just play the move like King you sick or
what King g6 is illegal play move like
King f6 well once again you are just
running in to this this problem over
here so rook f1 check instead now King
efore King e6 is played king d4 is check
king d6
Rick f4 is shay TAS ekend
see for ruk f4 is check but now king b5
in this king stays active on the Queen
side and black is very quickly going to
find his pawns indefensible
note that if this rook tries to cut the
King off from this direction
that's when Wyatt can sort of switch
ideas here going for stuff on the on the
Kings side
additionally the movie rook d3 is here
for white note that ever after King f5
there actually is an annoying rook d5
check when Ricky five would be met with
her up d3 and kind of disaster so I
can't really play King of five just yet
but rook d3 would get the job done with
this King still getting over here
anyways okay so instead King e6 and now
this King runs over here rook e8 is the
next great move by by Fabi the rook has
served its purpose defending this beep
on and now it switches ideas and it goes
for activity note rook d3 it's still not
playable still not playable due to Ric
d8 check Fabi always making sure his
opponent does not get active rook f4
plane instead going for similar ideas
but now it's too little too late
rook g8 is going to be a technical win
for Fabiano Cara Juana
so that is really the bulk of the
endgame right there we went through it
pretty quickly because the idea was
actually pretty simple the idea in these
end games is always to get King activity
King activity and ruika activity are
absolutely critical in these end games
so what does Fabi do you make sure his
opponent doesn't get activity and it
gets activity for himself so let's go
through that one more time super quickly
here he wins this pawn the black rook
gets active on b2 White's uses this rook
both and in an active role to cut off
the black King and as a defensive piece
as well
guarding all of the weaknesses he Shores
up this pawn structure over here and
then gets this King active finds the
path forest came to the Queen's side and
is simply technically winning soon after
that let's see how Fabi does it though
King b5 Rick g1 B
for he pushes both of these pounds up
the board Rick p1 Rick g8 now the Jeep
on runs King f6 now Kings c5 and after
king b6 black went ahead and and simply
resigned of course it's difficult to
stop this pawn from getting all the way
to b7 and then this pawn as well are
going to be simply too many threats
before the black rook and black king to
handle so once again really simple chess
here in the end game from Fabiano Cara
Juana
it's all about finding activity for your
king and making sure you're not giving
counter play for your opponent that is
the key to this endgame once again it is
really easy to draw this endgame if you
get sucked away by ideas of well sorry
g5 in the game getting sucked away by
ideas of just going a little bit crazy
sorry going a little bit crazy if I can
I'm missing a missing messing a blunder
it'd be one king f7 going a little bit
crazy with ideas of trying to checkmate
your opponent after you see the move h5
right you know you see the move h5 you
start trying to trying to go checkmate
them these ideas are how you draw the
game giving up counter play like this is
something you absolutely absolutely do
not want to do so avoid counter playing
these on games and the easy win is yours
okay that's going to be it for this
endgame let's move on to another one
which do I want to actually do let's do
the end game between Levon Aronian and
Santosh vadik this is another great game
from Levon Aronian who it is great to
see playing chess again in this nation's
Cup representing Team Europe I believe
either Team Europe or team rest of world
I'm not sure one of the two anyways
let's see it Levon in this game nobody
cares
he played a reverse Benoni in the
opening fun stuff but not the topic of
this lecture Knight takes d4 it a nice
little tactic for you guys look out for
that one
let me see you take stakes c5 sacrifices
the pawn back now he occupies some light
squares
good endgame stuff wait takes takes d3
and Bishop III what's going on
are we nearing an end game yet I feel
like there's one too many major pieces
on the board for me to call this an end
game oh okay
rook here takes takes now we are firmly
planted in an endgame so let me ask you
guys at home who would you rather be in
this end game of course bishops of
opposite colors so three choices here
white is better white is worse than
black is better or big equal position
should be a draw what do you guys think
what do you guys think
what do you guys think you're big equal
position big draw white is better or
black is better big draw equal position
so I actually tend to agree here this
position is more or less totally equal
if anything it would appear
superficially that black is the one with
all the chances as this d3 pawn
looks a bit more threatening than this
pawn on b2 however just because a
position is equal does not mean that the
game is going to end peacefully and that
is definitely going to be the case here
so let's see what Levon Aronian does to
take this equal position this position
that by all means should be drawn with
best play and how does he create chances
kind of out of nowhere
King h7 was played in the game so what
does he do he simply sets up a threat
against the g7 pawn that his opponent is
always going to have to be on the
lookout for and centralizes his Queen
note he's attacking and actually
defending with this move
stopping the move Bishop d5 with the
same threat for the opponent so Bishop
e8 instead hope sir scroll a little bit
too much Bishop e8 for the opponent
perhaps aiming for some similar stuff
King f2 by Levon and vidi was ready to
draw with Bishop f7 perhaps hoping his
opponent would play King g1 however you
know LaVon a true warrior indeed wanted
to play it for a little bit more so
let's see what LaVon played in this game
if you guys at home want to try and try
and find his move you're totally welcome
to totally welcome to of course the move
on place is g4 and as someone in the
chat said it's not not quite true in
this position but in these opposite
colored bishop end games it often comes
down to who is the attacker and in this
case white definitely has the more
offensive role with this Bishop and this
Queen stacked up against this black King
over here on on age 7 and when you're
the attacking player you get to play on
the same color as your bishop which
means the bishop for the opponent being
on the opposite color isn't really
ribbiting too much to the game and in
fact that is kind of the case here but
in this case black is already well
defended on g7 so it's difficult to say
that white really does have an advantage
note the move Queen f6 check is actually
playable playable here and this in fact
would just be a draw you know in fact
it's not even a difficult draw black can
just post up on the g6 square play move
h5 and pass forever with a bishop on c2
or even giving up this pawn it's it's
still a dead draw but of course white or
black wasn't really interested in going
for this pawn down endgame instead just
playing Bishop b3 claiming he has no
reason to be worse King III comes on the
board now Bishop c2 guarding the pawn
now King d2 LaVon brings his King over
to this Queen side block hating blacks
only passed upon but should be three and
the players repeated for a moment and
now LaVon decides once again to play on
with the move Queen a 7 black plays the
move Bishop c2 and then I'd like you
guys to try and find lavon's next move
this is the move that really shows the
fighting spirit from the armenian shows
you know perhaps he saw a little bit
deeper than than his opponent
wait to move and believe it or not win
the game
wait to move and win out of nowhere
I'll let the chat try and find this one
I don't want to spoil it for him it's a
good one it's a good one
okay someone had seen the game life so I
I guess they're not spoiling it for
everyone else I am now going to give
away the answer hopefully the people in
the chat have found it the answer of
course is the incredible move be for you
know be for is just out of nowhere
winning this game black of course
captures on be three on Poisson this is
legal I promise this is legal but now
not the move a four which would be a
huge blunder allowing B to when pond
scum off the board instead Bishop b2 and
suddenly none of the black pieces can
move how did it happen
I don't know Levon Aronian is a magician
none of the black pieces can move you
don't believe me try to move the Queen
you can't you just can't move the Queen
maybe you could go here I'll take but
now all of a sudden to try and move your
Bishop where you gonna go where you
gonna go to be one I'm gonna go hang out
on the a2 square is that where you're
gonna go you can't move the bishop none
of the black pieces can move a truly
incredible tactic from Levon Aronian
here a great one a great one to be sure
before the crazy move by Levon
highlighting how he expertly just pinned
down all of these black pieces you know
this Queen stuck to the g7 pawn this
bishop now stuck deep stuck to the d3
pawn and with b4 after Bishop or a takes
b3 Bishop b2 keeps this bishop entombed
on c2 a real study like endgame here by
LaVon to just win this position know if
black doesn't actually take on b3 this B
pond is in fact going to be far too
strong
b6 highlighting that this queen can't
move and then next thing you know in
this endgame this one is not going to be
a draw because the activity of the white
king is so powerful that this Bishop is
is just going to die just going to die
so that is is really the story of this
endgame
there should be two and then these were
the moves that were played black
eventually sacrifices this bishop plays
d2
Livan takes off the queens and takes off
this pawn and it is just a dead lost
position for black so of course black
didn't have to fall into this Bishop c2
was a bit too nonchalant if Bishop d5
had been played I mean I'm sure the game
would continue but you know it's it's
it's still gonna go on and white is
always going to have this nagging
pressure against g7 that is just going
to be slightly uncomfortable for for
black to be dealing with probably that's
why here even the move Queen g5 should
probably just be considered for black
just accept your slightly worse endgame
if you plant this King on g6 the fact of
the matter is this King can never attack
this pond and your king is never moving
off the g6 square you can do this or
this for the the remainder of the game
if the move be forever comes on the
board well now you are actually a bit
happier to play this move a takes b3
when one of the the white pieces is
going to be relegated to the defense at
this pawn so probably black should've
just tried to take the Queen's off in
this end game instead Bishop c2 and the
shocker b4 comes on the board winning
the entire game well done to LaVon
yes self entombment itself entombment
okay we have nine minutes left
hopefully that's enough time for me to
go over one last game for you guys this
one between Yong Nepal mushy and Hikaru
Nakamura in the big Russia versus United
States matchup here car with the black
pieces this game is so long that I'm
just going to skip to this position here
so many of you probably remember if the
Magnus Carlsen Invitational that just
happened where Hikaru had the white site
of a position that looked quite similar
to this one so in this case Macario
finds himself on the black side perhaps
Yan saw Hikaru win that game and thought
to himself
oh I don't I don't
try that so in this game Queen a6 played
f4 queen takes a five-night takes a 598
so the story of this end game is
actually this week c6 pawn here we see
yon putting a lot of pressure onto this
pawn but Hikaru is claiming that he has
a defensive setup that is unbreakable
this knight on b8 will guard this pawn
on c6 you can play King d7 for a second
defender and the key difference in this
game here I think is really that this e
v square is unusable to these Knights if
you remember the game Magnus Carlsen
Invitational 95 was a key move for Cara
Nakamura in that game to take some extra
space and more or less force his way
into the position now with this pawn on
b5 there's really no way for either
player to to break through here so a
karo for the next I'm not kidding
70 moves sits back in does nothing until
Yan gets frustrated that is the key here
you sit back and let your opponent try
to break through until Yan gets
frustrated and blunders and that's how a
carbon a chimera actually ended up
winning this game so I'm going to play
through these moves rather quickly I'm
gonna pause at the important moments Yan
tries age for trying to open things up
note Hikaru does not panic she just
leaves this pawn on g5 these end games
of course are all about invasion points
for the enemy King and if these Knights
can pile up against a particular
weakness so cargo is not necessarily
afraid of this as he still does have
this nice wall to keep these kings out
and if the opponent starts getting some
clever ideas of coming to f3 and
guarding or attacking this pawn well we
can start getting some clever ideas of
finding our own activity with a knight
on e4 well-placed to guard this weakness
and before you know it black might be
the one once again playing for an
advantage
so instead Knight b3 is played and now
with this move the karo does in fact
actually take off this age for pawn king
takes h4 and now Knight G 7
and Hikaru has set up his defensive
structure here this is the Great Wall of
Hikaru to keep yon out of the position
ninety-two played in the game trying to
rewrite over here now night at fates
Knight f3 car gives a check the King
steps back
King d89 h4 courtesies no reason to
trade trades are not always the way to
go about having the best defensive setup
in this case Cara thinks he can make use
of this night on e7 guarding all these
entry points King f3 and now the players
shuffle around for a little bit night c1
King f7 night b3 and then a car plays
another really nice move here and that
move is the move h5 he finds the moment
to simplify just a little bit further
now if takes of course the car will take
and after move like f5 the position is
just gonna be so incredibly dead drawn
that it's not even funny note that after
97 for example in this position you
would not want to play f5 giving the
King access to g5 but rather you know
you can play move like knight of
Knight f5 first and work to keep this
King out of your position then you can
play move like f5 and then it's just
just going to be dead so do you take h5
not played if g5 a kind of similar thing
might happen or Ricardo takes advantage
of this nice f5 square with the move
like 9 to 5 I think immediately yeah you
can even take first let's say
immediately just for example takes takes
and then it takes takes King here and
once again somehow it is black with the
past pawn G takes f6 for example and
these squares are still going to remain
guarded so ok
h5 by a car Knight a5 by young and now
after age 64 King takes g4 we do see 98
kind of asking for the King to invade
but now all of a sudden you've gone one
step too far and you have to look out
for your B for pawn so 98 f5 by Yan 97
guards this threatens this at
six King takes c6 9 back to g2 now if
night a six you're running into Knight
f4 check in 93 to guard just in time
so instead night back to e 8 was played
metaphor check King d7 night h5 King c7
and once again a Caro has set up his
defensive structure here this is all you
really have to do in these end games
keep an eye on your weakness and ensure
that the enemy King cannot invade and
that's exactly what Carter does 93 now
King b7 no Caro is just passing the time
King f7 97 night at 5 now it's suddenly
making a threat a night h4 is a check
King g3 985 King f2 avoids the
repetition night back to g7 night b7
okay I'm just saying the moves here
let's skip ahead to win good things
finally happen like e to f5 knight back
to f7 or eise evan rather they repeat a
few more times
kora keeps giving checks this is his
defensive setup with the great wall
constructed King g7 King F 7 e7 king f7
984 check and back to f5 now at g3 check
and we're getting there soon I promise
I told you it was literally 70 most of
this 98 king of 397 and akaru
once again starting to create some
threats on b4 so white has to be a
little bit careful 92 night a 693
defense night back to c7 I need to see
196 more shuffling 98 king g6 coming up
793 and and here we go 96 9 age 6 the
King gets forced back in just a little
bit Knight back to d8 to guard this pawn
that f4 is a check King up to King up to
f5 rather at night h5 king g6 and we're
getting there soon and yes this is the
point when Yan got impatient so of
course those past however many moves
let's see remove 99 when was the last
pawn did they actually reach the 50 move
roll I'm confused
a second here it really felt like okay
this was literally move 49
I think for white on move 50 the guy
played f5 now I'm moving 99 he plays the
move efore so this is the point where
Yann perhaps got a little bit
over-ambitious here so this is the art
of of pressing too hard that's why I
wanted to show you guys this endgame I
know it took us a while to get here when
I moved 99 but sometimes your opponent
just does have a good enough defensive
structure and my playing moves like
efore you're running more risk than
you're gaining and with 95 comes on the
board King III and now D takes e4 so
Knight takes e4 of course makes sense by
white to regain the pun but now after
Knight G to e6 there's suddenly crusher
on d4 and rather than give yourself a
passed pawn you've just given your
opponent a passed pawn that's exactly
what car used to win this game Knight c3
on the board now Knight c7 by Hikaru
guards b5 and d5 King f4 Knight a six
challenges the b4 upon Knight a 2 and
all of a sudden look who is relegated to
being passive now it is this night this
is the act of night hitting b4 Knight
back to c7 though King e4 now after f5
check King he 5 is the final blunder
King f4 was required to actually put a
stop to this pawn here you can't really
give this check because then King me 5
and this pawn is hanging you can I guess
give this check but now after f4 you've
have given up at the e5 square so
instead though kingi five and after
Knight F 795 things all go downhill
quite rapidly for Yan this pawn pushes
the b4 pawn is given up and from here
the karo did manage to convert going up
to pawns and pushing them to victory
here when Jana Palma she resigned
so it went through that one really
really quickly for the number of moves
the point I wanted to get across is when
you feel like you're pressing like this
like yan did it's really easy
psychologically to get into the mindset
that you can't ever really lose you know
you're just pressing you're trying to
win you're trying to win but you
always have to be sure you're not
actually giving your opponent counter
chances and meanwhile from karu a master
class in creating a defensive structure
and just sticking to it holding the draw
until suddenly his opponent grants him
this nice winning chance hopefully you
guys enjoyed these end games from the
Nations Cup going on on chess calm I had
a lot of fun going over them if you're
watching live be sure to tune in to the
twitch channel directly after this for
analyzer games from watching the video
thank you very much for joining me my
name is Caleb Denby and I will see you
next time
[Music]
you